imagine if we could control
earthquake researchers have detected
strange radio signals coming from deep
space these mysterious radio waves might
just be bursts of cosmic energy from a
distant neutron star or it could be that
scientists have discovered a highly
Advanced civilization 90 light years
away from
Earth so what kind of civilization would
have the ability to send strong signals
like this well scientists classify
civilizations on something called the
kardashev scale it's a scale that
measures a civilization's technological
ability to harness energy while it's a
hypothetical scale that could eventually
have five or more levels most scientists
only refer to the first few but don't be
underwhelmed we're the only civilization
we know of and technically we're still
stuck on type
zero at this stage we've managed to
harness some but not all of our planet's
potential energy we consume about 18
trillion watts of power every year and
if we wanted to bump ourselves up to a
type 1 civilization we'd need to consume
over 500 times that every second to do
this we' need to harness store and
utilize all of the energy available to
us that includes all raw materials and
every bit of sunlight that reaches Earth
we'd also have to tame volcano
earthquakes and other Natural
Forces at the rate at which we're
developing now it's possible that we
could be a type 1 civilization within
the next 200 years
but whatever civilization scientists may
have discovered in the far reaches of
space could already be a type 2
civilization or
higher once our civilization has all of
the energy available on our home planet
under control and we graduate to a type
one on the kardashev
scale then we need to take the next step
time to crank up our energy consumption
to 10 billion times what it was before
to do this we'd need to harness not just
all the solar energy that reaches Earth
we'd need all of the energy our star
generates period if there is a type 2
civilization out there they're probably
using an incredible system to do this a
Dyson
Sphere they' build this Mega structure
around their star to collect all the
energy it radiates out in every
direction they could even assemble other
Dyson spheres around the first Dyson
Sphere to guarantee that little to know
energy
escapes but there's nothing simple about
this technology and that's why only
Advanced civilizations could construct
something like it for one a Dyson Sphere
must be larger than the star
itself and if these Mega structures are
bigger than Stars well they should be
easy to spot right well this could be
tricky once a civilization is finished
building the Dyson Sphere the mega
structure blocks nearly all of the
visible light from its star a
civilization this Advanced could make
its own solar system
invisible lucky for us visible light
isn't the only way to detect a star even
with a Dyson Sphere blocking its light a
star would still radiate heat and we
could detect the Star by the infrared
light it gives
off but that wouldn't be the only way we
might discover a civilization this
Advanced remember that strange radio
signal it originated about 90 light
years away from Earth coming from the
Star HD1 164
595 was this powerful radio signal
created by an alien race and
intentionally pointed toward Earth
a civilization able to pull this off
would need to be far more advanced than
our own this type 2 civilization would
be able to utilize the raw materials on
every planet in its star system and
maybe even Beyond they may have built
Fusion reactors that orbit their Planet
fueled with gas from other worlds with
hydrogen-rich
atmospheres and they might be mining
precious metals from rocky planets just
like Earth they could terraform other
planets into livable worlds for their
populations and they wouldn't live in
fear of civilization ending natural
disasters like asteroid impacts ice ages
or global warming because they'd have
Technical Solutions for these too this
alien civilization would be at the stage
on the kardashev scale where they'd be
able to master Interstellar travel but
if that's true there should be no reason
for them not to pop by for a visit
right well not so fast with all the
advanced technology they might have at
their disposal these aliens could be
waiting for us to catch up that way when
our civilizations meet we would do so as
equal
Partners who knows they could be so
Advanced that they're no longer a fully
biological race they could be more like
cyborgs with a mix of robotic and or
organic
material this would make them capable of
incredible things that humans could only
dream of but they wouldn't stop there an
advanced world like this would want to
go farther up the kardashev scale and as
they became a Type 3 civilization they'd
rely on something other than the power
of their own star system they would
harness the power of several stars in
their
Galaxy with this much power a
civilization would have no problem
meeting its ever growing energy needs
they'd just hook up another star when
they needed more
power if we ever Advanced to this level
we'd have 100 billion stars available to
harness in the Milky Way galaxy alone a
civilization like this would no doubt be
the rulers of their Galaxy and they'd
have the power to move entire star
systems merging them to harvest the
energy they need more efficient
efficiently so if one of these
civilizations existed well you could
detect them by observing the sudden
disappearance of many stars in a far
away Galaxy this could be a sign that
Dyson spheres have been constructed
around not just one but several
Stars a Type 3 civilization could
already be out there yeah after all
scientists have announced that they
found two galaxies with a highly unusual
amount of infrared light this is
something we usually observe in galaxies
where new stars are being born but some
unusual and sudden spikes in infrared
light could mean that we found the first
signs that civilizations many times more
advanced than us exist
[Music]
maybe imagine having the ability to live
forever travel anywhere in the universe
and harness enough power to create
wormholes well if you're part of the
ultra exclusive type 3 civilization Club
these are just some of the everyday
luxuries available so how could feeble
earthlings get to this level of power
but more importantly should we even try
how would our lives transform as a type
three
civilization would technology work for
us or against
us and what would it take to get to a
type four
civilization this is what if and here's
what would happen if we were a type
three
civilization on the kardashev scale
which measures a civil civilization's
technological ability to harness energy
we're stuck at a type zero to graduate
to type 1 we'd have to take full
advantage of all the Earth's energy and
any energy that comes our way such as
sunlight according to physicist Michio
Kaku we'll get there in a century or two
but to get to type two where we're able
to harness all the energy of our sun Dr
Kaku estimates we're a few thousand
years away which is frankly pretty
optimistic to reach type three where a
civilization harnesses the power of its
entire galaxy micho estimates that we're
looking at anywhere from 100,000 to 1
million
years so if we managed to fast for
forward 1 million years into the future
what would our lives look
like with the ability to harness nearly
Limitless energy from any planet or Star
within sight we could live anywhere we
wanted maybe we could build an even
better Earth or an entirely new solar
system from scratch looking for a
tropical beach Planet it's all yours or
how about a mushroom planet sure we can
do that Earth Mars and every planet in
our solar system might just be husks at
this point we would have mined them of
all their resources to build Dyson
swarms no I'm not talking about a swarm
of fancy vacuums but millions of energy
collecting satellites that could swarm
around a star and turn it into one big
battery but to truly become a Type 3
civilization we'd need swarms of Dyson
swarms collecting an unfathomable amount
of energy from all the stars in our
entire galaxy at this point humans would
have harnessed biotechnology to its
fullest and we would likely become a
race of cyborgs so Advanced we'd be
indiscernible from robots our new
favorite dance move might be called the
human over the past decade we've already
developed electrode implants that allow
amputees the ability to control
artificial limbs with their brains we
have brain implants that allow us to
hear and perceive color and Elon Musk is
working on melding AI with the human
brain with his company
neuralink just imagine where this techno
Evolution will take us in a million
years
to survive warp speed travel we may very
well have to modify our flesh and Bone
bodies into something more
resilient this is all wishful thinking
though as AI improves exponentially
robots will rapidly outsmart and
outnumber humans they might consider us
to be too useless whiny and well
obsolete if we're lucky they'll keep us
around as pets or Wildlife or we may
have to start acting more like them
ridding ourselves of any emotion or
moral conscience at this point AI would
be self-replicating on an exponential
scale and could strip a planet with
little remorse for whatever creatures
live there I'm sorry guys but you all
know our slogan we are the board work
and resistance is
futile with almost Limitless resources
as a Type 3 civilization we would have
enough power to harness plank energy the
energy of
SpaceTime physics at this level would be
vastly different from what we know today
according to Einstein's theory of
relativity our ability to travel faster
than light is impossible but at the
plank scale we could build a wormhole to
get
around as a Type 3 civilization with an
almost infinite energy Supply we
wouldn't need resource management at
this point we'd be Godlike with enough
biotech to make us Immortal and nearly
indestructible if anything stood in our
way well we could snap our fingers and
call it a
day over time we would eventually
exhaust our our entire Galaxy's
resources in this case we'd need to
advance to become a type four or five
civilization to explore and harvest
energy from the rest of the
universe without a resource limit as a
type four civilization we'd have no
reason to Value the universe around us
beyond our own technological gains in
other words we'd get pretty bored like
getting 100% completion in your favorite
video game on the most challenging
setting imagine a world where Humanity
has not only gained the ability to
travel and populate space but has
progressed even further than that
Humanity can now control and navigate
multiple
universes welcome to one of the most
advanced civilizations ever thought of a
type five
civilization what is a type five
civilization what would it mean for
Humanity and how would we get to this
point this is what if and here's what
would happen if Humanity became a type
five
civilization okay so before we get to
our epic type five civilization we first
need to start at
zero this is unfort Al where Earth Is
Right Now a type zero civilization is
one that's reliant on things like fossil
fuels and still struggling with issues
like climate change yeah we've sent
people to the moon and Rovers to Mars
but we're far from Interstellar travel
and although we have lots of
technological advancements we're still
vulnerable to things like natural
disasters and
pandemics so although Earth Earth is
highly advanced in many ways we still
have a long way to go before we reach a
type one or two or five
civilization how do we get
there well before we get to that what
are these civilizations anyway and who
came up with them it's known as the
kardashev
scale developed by Nikolai kardashev in
1964 the scale categorizes a
civilization according to its
technological capabilities and energy
consumption originally the scale only
involved type one 2 and three
civilizations but it's since been
expanded to include type four and five
now while civilizations 4 and 5 are
mostly speculative and theoretical
civilizations 1 through three could
happen
someday so how could humans become a
type five civilization hm Who whoo whoo
not so fast first we need to get to a
type one there's no way a civilization
can jump from a zero all the way to five
so let's get started type one
civilization a type 1 civilization would
be a massive improvement from where we
are now on Earth as a type one we could
harness all the energy available to us
on the planet imagine being able to
harness the power of the oceans and the
sun things like hurricanes and
earthquakes would become minor
inconveniences and all our energy would
be
renewable now to get to this point the
main thing we'd need to focus on would
be energy transition shifting from
non-renewable to renewable energy
sources would be the key priority and it
would need to be done at a global scale
think entire deserts filled with solar
panels wind turbines covering the clouds
and ocean thermal energy conversion
plants other scientific advancements
would also be essential things like
Quantum Computing and advanced AI would
be key parts of helping us transition
into this new
civilization but it's not just about the
technology we'd also need some sort of
global governance to help unify the
world to tackle these massive challenges
experts think that this might happen in
the next Century or two
but we don't have time to wait that long
so let's fast forward and move on to the
next type of civilization we got four
more to
go type 2
civilization this would be a massive
leap on all fronts of energy and
technological advancement being a type
two would mean that we'd be able to
build extreme Mega structures like this
Dyson Sphere this would allow us to
harness the power of the Sun and and
with that our energy capability would be
virtually Limitless we could innovate
our way to incredible technological
Heights instead of being Tethered to
Earth we now have the power to travel to
new planets and start populating them
Mars Venus and other planets in our
solar system would become our new homes
and overall the solar system would
become a Utopia with humans having this
much power we'd move Beyond things like
scarcity
war and
inequality a unified Galactic government
would span across our star
system but it would take some hard work
becoming a type 2 civilization would
require all of Humanity's effort and
span multiple
Generations type 3
civilization you think harnessing the
power of our Earth and Sun is epic how
about an entire galaxy well that's what
you can expect when transitioning to a
Type 3
civilization things like black holes
billions of stars and other celestial
bodies would all be at Humanity's
disposal to harness and use this could
allow for Wormhole travel we can
instantly travel to distant points in
the galaxy and if that wasn't enough
we'd also have the ability to terraform
different planets however we please I
kind of want a ski on
Venus type four
civilization okay now is where things
get really crazy A type four
civilization is beginning to reach a
point beyond our current understanding
of the universe and physics so naturally
there would be some weird aspects to
this upgraded version of humanity being
able to terraform planets and control
celestial bodies was so last
Civilization now we reshape destroy or
create entire
worlds we would have unlimited power
having mastered the resources of the
entire universe things like artificial
intelligence would become so Advanced by
this point that they'd become part of
the structure of the universe with that
we'd be able to control virtually every
aspect of everything we could manipulate
time and create different
timelines create new life forms and
different kinds of matter and on top of
all that in a type four civilization
we'd be able to transcend biological
limitations and achieve a form of
immortality pretty crazy right well
we're not even done
yet type 5
civilization similar to a type four
civilization a a type five civilization
would be dealing with problems and
obstacles that we can't even
comprehend but what we do know is that
this civilization would be able to do
virtually anything the people or
whatever they would evolve to at this
point would essentially become gods they
could instantly create new universes
with specific conditions that they could
use to experiment with new life they
could effectively create their own
simulations ones that are even more
complex than the world we live in
today and the key difference would be
that a type five civilization would have
access to and control of multiple
universes yeah instead of being limited
to just one puny Universe we would now
become a multiversal
civilization this means everything we
could do in one Universe our control of
energy and our access to resources would
now be multiplied across the entire
Multiverse now what happens after that
is almost
incomprehensible a type six or seven
civilization May mean that Humanity
merges with the fabric of reality
itself we might go beyond our physical
reality and who knows what happens after
that but no doubt it it'd be pretty
crazy imagine a world where you're not
even human you can create universes with
ease and control
time this could be a reality in an
incredibly Advanced and I mean an
incredibly Advanced
civilization okay we've talked about
what if Humanity reaches type 1 through
type five civilizations but what if we
take it a step further
what if we become a type six or seven
civilization What would life be like
then is a type 7 civilization even
possible what would humans look like and
why might something like this be a
terribly bad
idea this is what if and here's what
would happen if Humanity became a type
seven
civilization okay before we start let's
quickly recap the types of civilizations
we've covered so far I'll make it quick
type one civilization okay here Humanity
gains control of Earth and we're able to
access all the power on the planet type
two civilization well this is where we
harness the power of the Sun and start
to populate other planets like Mars and
Venus type three
Civilization now humanity is controlling
the entire galaxy
commanding the power of black holes
multiple stars and all other celestial
bodies these civilizations were
conceived by Nikolai kardashev who
created the kardashev scale it's a
hypothetical framework used to measure a
civilization's ability to harness
technological power civilizations 1 to
three were developed by kardashev
himself but the list has since expanded
in a more speculative manner to add
types 4 through 7
here are some of them in Fast Forward
type four civilization well Humanity
gains the ability to populate and
control the entire
universe type five Civilization now
humanity is controlling multiple
universes we've become a multiversal
civilization so that's 1 through five
but what happens next is pretty
ridiculous and we should preface that
this goes beyond the expanded kardashev
scale making these next civilizations
purely speculative they're also getting
so Advanced that scientists claim these
civilizations are hard to even
comprehend we'll be dealing with
problems we don't even know about yet
but hey you guys asked for this so let's
strap in things are about to get
weird type 6
civilization a type 6 civilization will
see some significant upgrades from our
type 5
civilization instead of controlling
parts of multiple universes well we can
now control
everything yeah we can instantly create
or destroy any Universe of our choosing
not only that but time would become a
new toy for us to play with we can now
manipulate it any way we want feel free
to create multiple timelines maybe I'll
create one with where I'm the president
or I have blonde hair or maybe one where
I'm super
jacked and with all these multiverses
Humanity wouldn't be the only
Civilization by now there's a good
chance that we've discovered or even
created multiple civilizations of other
new species across different universes
ones that range from type zero to type
five and of course with us at the top of
the food chain Humanity would be the
rulers of these
civilizations or we might view them as
cultures that are lesser than us maybe
we'll just observe them in the same way
we do with ant colonies or zoo animals
and what would you look like in a type 6
civilization well definitely not like
you do now or I guess you could if you
wanted to let me show you some examples
you'd have the power to control reality
and matter so if you wanted you could
look like you do now or you could look
like the rock there's also a chance that
we would no longer be biological beings
as we've progressed through these
civilizations technology and AI have
only been getting more advanced we may
have fused with artificial intelligence
becoming Robo human
hybrids maybe we'd look like
this and if you're more creative who
knows what you could be you could be an
a Al a Godlike giant or go a more
efficient route and become a ball of
energy one that could move around
universes with ease now if you think a
type 6 civilization sounds nuts well
wait till you see what's
next type seven
civilization as we progress through
these civilizations things are only
getting more ridiculous weird and
confusing we're now officially at the
point where this civilization is almost
Beyond human
comprehension we'd have the ability to
create alter and Destroy more
universes ultimately controlling
everything one of the key differences
between a type six and seven
civilization would be us being able to
control the
Omniverse okay again this is entirely
speculative but the Omniverse is even
bigger than the
Multiverse it contains an infinite
amount of universes both real and
fictional it shows every conceivable
timeline and contains realities we can't
even understand
yet humans or whatever we're called at
this point would be able to transcend
any form of physical or metaphysical
reality our new forms are unimag inable
at least with our current
knowledge we'd be past the point of
having to worry about dying or any form
of suffering instead humans might exist
in a state of constant Bliss
Enlightenment and
Euphoria we might be able to exist
simultaneously in multiple realities and
timelines able to see everything in the
past present and future with all this
incredible power it kind of begs the
question
would Humanity even want to get to this
point would we even be considered human
I mean Society has progressed so far
that we're not even experiencing the
things that make us who we are instead
of hanging out with our loved ones and
following our passions we're now
Invincible beings who have transcended
our current feeble human needs and ideas
we're building new realities and playing
God
we'd also have plenty of existential
challenges in this period with Humanity
being so powerful and controlling
everything well what would there be for
us to do we've already conquered the
Earth the universe and now the
Omniverse where does Humanity progress
and what would we have left to
accomplish we wouldn't experience any
adversity or challenges two essential
aspects of our human life so as exciting
as these things sound would it be worth
it at what point will we attain type two
status well remember now we're talking
about centuries to maybe a thousand
years into the future this means
building the first Starships so we're
going to go far beyond the solar system
and reach out to the nearby
[Music]
Stars
so Pete how you doing
today I'm good how are you doing you
seem surprised that I'm asking you how
you're doing it's just an odd way to
start not you say it every week but it
it seemed like you were putting me on
the spot for some reason well I mean in
this case I was actually concerned I am
concerned with how you're doing but more
in the context of energy how are you
feeling
energetically uh well I mean here we're
sitting in August of 2020 and uh just a
hope is this the tail end of the
pandemic really I don't know uh I think
like a lot of people who are working
from home not everybody's working from
home but I am a lot of people are taxed
they're uh they're they've expended a
lot of their energy they're low and I
mean I think most people would answer
the question the same way most people
feel they don't have enough energy they
could use more energy because at the end
we're all energy including our planet
okay now I see where you're going with
this you're you're talking about and
because of probably the uh the topic of
today's show everything is energy
everything is energy and in this case
how planets are sort of categorized
according to the card she scale which is
something we'll get into later there are
type one type two type three
civilizations and it's according to how
much energy they can harness from in
this case type two that you harness from
the Sun I we have done a few kardashev
scale like videos on uh what if um and I
don't recall are we a type one well bad
news we're not a type one yet we're
actually type zero which is not
something that yeah it feels depressing
but we have nowhere to go but up okay
which is another way to look at it's
kind of like type two would be more like
solar power on steroids okay solar power
on steroids so it's like the sun but
we're getting all of our power from the
Sun we're able to harness All That Power
from the Sun and store it too yes and
store it which as you can imagine would
allow us to do a whole bunch of things
not things that I would necessarily
understand nor did I really understand
this prior to probably hours ago but
that's why we have guests on the show
because we want people to be able to
come on and explain some of these
complicated topics like what if Earth
became a type 2 civilization and in this
case lucky enough to have somebody who's
a bit of an expert on the subject and
who we've also had on the show before
yeah we have it's uh Professor meio Kaku
who's extremely uh smart and well
respected and and followed by a lot of
people and really one of the people who
are most cited and quoted when you're
talking about today's W if what if the
Earth became a type 2
[Music]
civilization miio Kaku is known as a
futurist a great communicator and a
popularizer of science he first
graduated Suma from Harvard University
in 1968 and received his PhD from
Berkeley in
1972 Kaku has expertise in several
Fields such as hadronic physics super
symmetry super gravity super string
theory and super Quantum no not super
quantum physics just quantum physics
he's also quite the medium Haven with
multiple best-selling books to his name
including his most recent the future of
humanity he also hosts two radio shows
and appears regularly in television
series exploring space physics and the
future he's currently the City College
of New York's Henry seat professor of
theoretical physics where he's been
teaching for 35
years Professor Kaku welcome back to
what if
discussed glad to be on the show and
we're always glad to have you and sure
as Peter and I talked about off the top
it's it's a complicated subject this
type one type two civilizations if you
don't know the kardashev scale uh and of
course I think we did our best to try to
understand it and explain it but this is
why you're here because obviously this
is something that you're considered uh
one of the experts on this planet so
first of all please clarify what is the
kardashev scale and what is a type one
type two type three
civilization well we physicists are
tired of talking about flying saucers
and Little Green Men and speculating
about life in space I'm a physicist we
use energy energy to rank civilizations
in outer space a type one civilization
is planetary they consume all the energy
that they receive from the Sun for
example they control the weather the
type two is Stellar they control all the
energy output of the Mother's Son sort
of like the the Federation of planets in
Star Trek they've colonized a few of the
neighboring planets neighboring star
systems but not much more then there's
type three type three is galactic they
roam the galactic space Lanes they can
harness the energy of a 100 billion
stars in the galaxy sort of like uh Star
Wars Star Wars would be an example of a
type three Galactic Civilization now
what are we do we play with the weather
play with volcanoes and play with
earthquakes do we play with the sun do
we play with black holes throughout the
Galaxy no we are type
zero we don't even rate on this scale
disapp we get our energy from dead
plants oil and coal but we are about a
hundred years away from attaining type
one status for example the internet what
is the internet internet it is the first
type One telephone system to be
Unleashed in this Century what language
will this type one civilization speak
well already English and Mandarin
Chinese are the two greatest languages
on the internet and what is the European
Union what is NAFTA what are all these
trade blocks the beginning of a
primitive type one planetary economy now
if you keep this scale up at what point
will we attain type two status that is
leave this solar system and start to
explore the nearby Stars well you just
take out a slide rule or a calculator
you can calculate that in just a few
thousand years we will be type two like
Captain Kirk now Captain Kirk lives in
the 23rd Century so that's about right
uh a little early but still well on the
scale that Nikolai ctera formulated in
the
1960s then you hit type three in about a
100,000 years wow and why is that
because that's the energy that you
attain the plun energy the plon energy
is the energy of SpaceTime it's when
space becomes unstable wormholes develop
black holes Gateway hyperspatial
gateways through space and time that's
the plank energy the plank energy is a
quadrillion times more powerful than the
large hron collider outside Geneva ssin
and why do I mention that because once
you attain the plank energy wormholes
maybe even time travel is a possibility
wow um let's bring it back down to earth
and uh and uh talk about type two I I
was asking off the top whether a type
two civilization was simply like solar
power on steroids yes now I know you're
not going to quote me in your next book
as a genius Insight but uh how close is
that idea to toh what type two means
well type two does not mean simply
getting sunlight from the Sun it means
playing with the sun itself for example
a Dyson Sphere would envelop the entire
sun with a sphere to absorb 100% of the
energy output of a star that's a Dyson
Sphere and astronomers think that well
we're not sure but we may have the
signals from some potential candidates
of being a type two civilization in
outer space there's a star called Tabby
star which drops in intensity by about
25% some people think that maybe a
gigantic Jupiter siiz planet moves in
front of the star absorbing all its
energy and perhaps that is a Dyson
Sphere in outer space Oh and a type two
civilization would be like Star Trek the
Federation of planets they've colonized
a small quadrant of the Galaxy would be
a type two
civilization um energy is something that
we I don't know it I don't mean we don't
talk about energy because we talk about
energy but as important as energy is to
our day-to-day lives and our functions
be in on this planet survive but even
Beyond you'd think we'd have even more
Focus I think we take it for granted
obviously just walk into a room turn on
a light switch Etc but as you said
earlier we we still are at a pretty
primitive level of harnessing energy
which is again fossil fuels how
important is it that we let's say
fastforward our harnessing of solar
power to not only get to type two
civilization one day but to expedite the
evolution of this species
well let's take a look at it
historically throughout most of human
history for 99% of human history we had
about a quarter of a horsepower per
person the strength of your left hand
and right hand and that's it folks that
was the energy output for most of human
civilization about a quarter of a
horsepower then when we domesticated
horses about 10,000 years ago we went
from a quarter of a horsepower to one
horsepower
and that began what is called
civilization cities armies Empires began
to be formed and then just 300 years ago
we discovered the steam engine and as a
consequence we went from one horsepower
to maybe 10 horsepower in a buggy in a
locomotive now of course you have access
to thousands of horsepower and in fact
we're going to use that energy to rock
it into outter space so so you see that
the progress of civilization can be
mapped by the progress in energy
harnessing that we've been able to
harness thousands of horsepowers for one
astronaut while before it was only the
strength of your left hand and your
right hand now you mentioned energy
sources of the future solar is one but
there's another one I think that is even
more important and that's fusion power
now fusion power is still a few decades
away but fusion power is the power of
the universe wow W it's what makes the
sunshine it's what makes the stars
twinkle and we're going to be able to I
think in a few decades harness that
fusion power on the planet Earth to give
us unlimited amounts of energy from
seawater seawater is the basic fuel for
Fusion plants and we have one in France
it's called the
ier fusion reactor in Kardash France
built by the European Union with the
help from the United States and Russia
and Japan and we hope to get Fusion off
the ground in the coming
decades well just so we book you in far
enough in advance i' just like you to
put in your calendar that when that
happens we'd like to have you back on
the show cuz ideally you you and I would
still be alive Peter we'd still be doing
what if discussed but uh like right now
I would say let's just put a pin in that
for now let's say we jump in the time
machine and go right there the what if
time machine Peter started up yes we
haven't used it in a while
so let's say all the theoreticals are
behind us we are now at that point where
we are a type two civilization what are
some of the kind of cool things that
people would be sort of fascinated by
that a type 2 civilization as Earth
would be able to do whether it's
controlling the weather the atmosphere
uh you know blowing asteroids out of the
SK like what are some of the things that
we should be able to expect as a type
two
civilization well remember now we're
talking about centuries to maybe a
thousand years into the future well we
have pretty much colonized the entire
solar system out to Pluto and maybe out
to the nearby Stars uh we're going to
build the first Starship perhaps within
100 200 years NASA already has the 100
star 100e Starship program looking at
potential propulsion systems for a
Starship uh for example antimatter
engines uh Fusion engines um even Ramjet
Fusion engines these are all possible
engines for Starships now we're not
talking warp drive to get warp drive
you'd have to be type three but by the
time you're type uh one and aspiring
toward type two this means building the
first Starships so we're going to go far
beyond the solar system and reach out to
the nearby Stars there's even a program
called the Breakthrough starshot program
uh Stephen Hawking uh the my late
colleague was a member of that program
and he believed that yes we should build
the first Starship not in a few hundred
years but in this Century just in this
Century build the first
Starship well one of the great things
about having you is that regardless of
where we're at individually or
collectively I'm always optimistic and
excited after I I speak to mokaku
because you see the future in such a way
that is uh especially in these times uh
encouraging and exciting and and gives
us a reason to sort of you know look
forward beyond our sort of day-to-day
problems and be excited about the it's
interesting because we talked about you
know Homo sapiens being around for
200,000 years and Professor Kaku is
saying you know all you had for power
was you know half a horsepower and now
we're hundred years away probably yes
and I mean a 100 years away we couldn't
fly or or sorry 100 you know a little
over 100 years ago we couldn't fly so
and then you know 50 years later 60
years later we're sending people to the
moon so as as you are always Adept at
doing you get us sort of steered in the
right direction we're going to have uh
Professor Kaku on later if you want to
listen to this full in-depth interview
beyond our conversation that we just had
click on the link below because a
special treat we are going to be
breaking down uh your most recent New
York Times bestseller the future of
humanity I don't think it's overstating
it to say that this is one of those
times where you want to be thinking
about the future of humanity but
especially the insights and the
Visionary uh perspectives that you have
in the book give us a little idea of
what we're going to be hearing about uh
and what people can expect to find in
the book the future of
humanity well you know the the dinosaurs
did not have a space program they did
not that's why they're not here today
there are no dinosaurs joining us for
this interview today because they got WP
out they were clueless they didn't know
what get them well we do have a space
program and it's inevitable that we're
gonna have crises for example volcanic
eruptions meteor impacts pandemics we
know they're going to be crises of the
future and we need an insurance policy
an insurance policy to make sure that
Humanity survives no matter what
catastrophes hit the planet Earth and
the main stumbling block preventing that
was a four-letter dirty word cost it
cost $10,000 to put a pound of anything
into orbit around the planet Earth
that's your weight in gold think of your
body made out of solid gold that's what
it costs just to put you in orbit around
the planet Earth well now prices are
dropping because Elon Musk and others
are perfecting the reusable rocket
because of competition because of
private public public
collaboration the price of space travel
is dropping like a rock this means that
in the future Mom and Dad may be able to
go to outer space and I would even
predict that our grandkids may have the
option of honeymooning on the
moon cool not the Dark Side of the Moon
though because that's not a good way to
start a relationship little more private
um so again more with Dr Kaku uh about
everything future of humanity you don't
want to miss this so click on the link
below and you're going to get a really
in-depth dive into a rabbit hole that's
going to cover so many topics about the
short medium and long-term future of
Humanity on this planet so yes I guess
we have a lot to look forward to would
be the glass half full because we're
type zero as as Professor Kaku talked
about we're hundreds of years away from
probably being a type one and thousands
of years away from being a type two this
is is and like I mentioned is this is uh
heartening for me as opposed to
disheartening for me in that like I say
the
human Homo sapiens have been here for
200,000 years and all the progress we've
made is basically to get to here and he
thinks in a 100 years 200 years we could
be a type one civilization my gosh like
how incredible is that progression in
100 years compared to the last 200,000
years I'd love to see that on the news
more right because
it's so easy as he talked about that we
we get so focused on the present and you
know if you're a Zen Buddhist you'd say
well that's where you want to be you
want to be in the moment but we also get
fixated on this particular time as
though this is you know this is the the
future of the species is basically the
next 10 no it's hundreds of years
thousands of years regardless of even
what happens in the short term we and
the planet are going to be around a long
time in some form and it seems C crazy
obviously as we sit here today that the
energy that we use and harness is still
you know as he said like you know plants
and and and fossil fuels when you have
this decaying dinosaurs decaying
dinosaurs and the focus on the sun isn't
new but hearing this you think man if we
really focused all our attention on
solar power and then you know further
harnessing that power so we've got this
enormous yellow burning ball of fuel
that I can feel on my face when I walk
down the street it's burning all day
long I mean certainly we our Earth
rotates but why are we not expending all
our energy expending all our energy into
capturing the energy from something
that's free something that's incredibly
powerful and something that's so close
rather than like you
know bugging around with all this junk
underneath the the dirt we're the only
species in in the world that actually
has the ability to delay its own
Evolution because we have we've known
this for 50 60 years that obviously
there's a way to get solar power uh you
know make it ubiquitous around the world
and essentially make energy as close to
free as possible but our Focus hasn't
been there our Focus has been in other
ways and of course once you have that
link to your economy nobody's in a rush
to sort of change the status quo and
that's kind of been the case I think
though not only is the is the will there
by most people or many people around the
world I think it's starting to see that
the the the political currency is there
as well so I think we're doing the show
in 10 years it's a different story
because I think we're going to be way
further down the line on way more solar
and way less years we're 10 years closer
to that you know 30 years in which we're
all going to die if we don't stop
burning fossil fuels and treating the
planet like we don't have a great
history as being proactive but we have a
pretty good history as being reactive
are we the only uh species that could
end our own Evolution as well I would
think so outside of lemmings I think
Lemmings can just run off cliffs but as
a whole I mean all over the world they
can't coordinate their I mean it's it's
it's funny because we're supposed to be
the smartest species in the world yet we
have that unique ability which is you
could argue not
smart exactly if you want more with
Professor M Kaku like we said there's
the full audio podcast click on the link
below and you'll get about 20 more
minutes with us and Professor meio Kaku
it's going to be really interesting
trust me talking about the future of
humanity which we're kind of doing here
but of course at a kindergarten level so
if you want to hear somebody who really
has an incredibly Visionary perspective
on and exciting and optimistic
perspective on the future of the species
Humanity the planet Etc you're going to
want to stick around for this because
again every time we talk to meio Kaku we
we usually leave you know kind ofil
smiling and feeling a lot better about
things he's he's talking about things
that make you happy rather than it's not
the end of the world for him it's the
possibilities of what we can do well
said Peter what are the possibilities of
you coming back and watching another
what if discussed maybe next week well
why don't you because this one's over
thanks for joining us here on Whata if
[Music]
discussed
imagine if we could control earthquakes
and tsunamis to generate power or maybe
even terraform every planet in the solar
system these are just a couple of the
things that might happen if human
civilization was to advance in the
future so how can humans get to this
point what other advancements will
happen
and What Makes Us think we'll even
progress this
far this is what if and here's what
would happen if we became a type one
civilization Global civilizations can be
categorized into what's known as the
kardashev scale this measures a
civilization's ability to use all the
energy available to it and is scaled
from 1 to
three currently Humanity doesn't even
reach type 1
civilization this is because humans
don't use all the forms of energy on
Earth we use wood coal and oil but
there's a lot more so what would change
if Humanity evolved into one of these
types of
civilizations being a type 1
civilization means we would have
complete control over all the energy on
Earth this means that we'd say goodbye
to fossil fuels since they're limited
and
unsustainable instead we could use the
wind sunlight and water for our energy
needs and since this energy is so
accessible you may no longer need to pay
for your power bill in a type 1
civilization we'd continuously be using
energy it would be as essential as
oxygen we would also start using natural
disasters to our advantage tsunamis
could be used to produce energy and
earthquakes could potentially be used to
terraform parts of the
world with us having complete control
over our planet's energy sources we
could also control the
weather if an area of the world were
suffering through a drought we could
disperse rainclouds over it and bring it
back to life Humanity could also say
goodbye to global warming at as we'd be
able to bring the atmosphere back to
carbon neutral and control our planet's
temperatures casualties from natural
disasters would also be reduced as we'd
be able to predict when and where they
might happen and not only that but we'd
be able to live on places on Earth we'd
never have dreamed of before like in the
water as well as in climates that used
to be unsuitable for us humans
y living in a type 1 civilization would
be pretty great but with things being
this perfect we might get a little
bored so what if we took Humanity one
step further and became a type 2
civilization or even a type
three a type 2 civilization means we
could harness the energy of the Sun and
use it not just on Earth but throughout
our solar
system we could use its power to travel
to and terraform Mars or even a planet
like
Neptune becoming a Type 3 civilization
would allow us to use all the energy in
the
galaxy and